[Musique]
nous sommes armés pour combattre le
virus nous sommes d'armes et nous
l'avons battu une première fois
et puis nous avons aussi nous avons
aussi l'expérience internationale
on sait ce qui ne marche pas dans
certains pays nous allons réinstaurer un
couvre-feu sur paris peut-être ile de
france c'est le ministre de l'intérieur
qu'il précisera dans la journée on
arrêtait va sortir moins d'une heure
après matignon dément cette décision
n'est absolument pas arrêté à ce stade
cette mesure va être concertés avec la
municipalité parisienne par la
préfecture de police
une décision sera prise dans les
prochains jours on n'a jamais vu une
chose pareille
le porte parole du gouvernement quand un
passant dans la rue c'est pas une
personne bien informée
c'est quelqu'un dont c'est le travail la
mission officielle annonce une mesure
qui est démenti par le chef du
gouvernement
c'est donc le poste de pilotage 123 une
forme de turbulence incontrôlée faut
vraiment que la communication
gouvernementale se re plein ces
retraites soit clarifiée ce porte parole
a manqué de sang froid il a jeté une
idée parmi parmi d'autres mais il ne
peut pas faire ça il ne peut pas faire
ça et puis monsieur déconfinement c'est
monsieur confinement aujourd'hui
n'imprime pas rien de ce qu'il dit
d'ailleurs ne suscite le moindre
commentaire
on peut pas affronter une période aussi
dur avec un bricolage et un amateurisme
de ce niveau là c'est juste pas
acceptable dans une telle situation
gabriella talent et porte parole d'un
gouvernement qui ne gouverne plus d'un
gouvernement fantoche en quelque sorte
puisque on le sait les décisions
désormais s'agissant de la crise
sanitaire ne sont plus prises en conseil
des ministres elles sont prises dans le
cadre de ce qu'on appelle le conseil de
défense qui est devenu en quelque sorte
un conseil des ministre bis si on veut
que le confinement réussissent et c'est
nécessaire parce que sinon 23e
pour qu'il réussisse il faut qu'il soit
compris il faut de la pédagogie il faut
de la cohérence sur la clarté
non on a le sentiment que c'est kafka à
la tête du pouvoir c'est quoi que ne
sont que l'expression d'un gouvernement
qui à mon avis ne maîtrise pas la
situation est donc comme erreurs sur
erreurs
il ya un certain nombre d'attroupement
qui ont encore lieu le soir parfois tard
dans certaines rues des villes d'île de
france et qui peuvent être corrélé au
maintien ouvert d'un certain nombre de
commerces qui est essentiel en soirée le
préfet nous a donc interrogé sur la
possibilité d'aller fermer et ses
commerces à partir d'une certaine heure
en soirée de manière à éviter ces
entreprises et regroupements je crains
et c'est ce que vous devriez craindre qu
in fine et nous soyons en ce moment
inefficace solitairement et est
destructeur économiquement
j'aurais dû être plus clair sur la
méthode que nous avons retenu c'est à
dire prise de contacts et échanges avec
les élus locaux avant qu'une quelconque
décision puisse être prise qu'en la
république est confronté à la plus grave
crise sanitaire qu'elle ait subie depuis
des décennies on n'appelle pas les mères
serviteur de la république a violé les
lois de la république
ça n'est pas possible le risque c'est à
terme chez faut bien voir ce qui se
passe aux etats unis le risque c'est la
guerre civile
c'est les français monte les uns contre
les autres c'est un moment de caen qui
ne se parlent plus le moment est donc
venu pour que soit réfléchi à temps
puisque le plan de déconfinement a été
un échec total et que apparemment n'a
pas l'air de prévoir mieux pour la suite
qu'on se mette à prévoir et en
particulier un système général
alternatif au confinement total les prés
de 20 heures hier soir des tirs
résonnent dans les rues du centre de
vienne
je demande à la population de rester
chez elles ou si elle est en lieu sûr
d'y rester de suivre l'actualité
je ne peux pas vous dire s'il sera
possible de reprendre la vie publique
comme d'habitude
cela dépendra beaucoup de la possibilité
d'attraper ou d'éliminer les suspects
rapidement les forces de l'ordre
interviennent elles abattent un
agresseur et sécurisé le secteur selon
la police autrichienne
six lieux différents ont été visés et je
pense que cette attaque n'a rien
d'innocent elle dit
si la volonté de nos ennemis de
s'attaquer à ce qu'est l'europe
cette terre de liberté de culture de
valeurs et donc nous ne céderons rien